始めを追う gitter ライナーわぁ i promise to web
これじゃあ肇社長ですあゆみ今日は静岡のお家から動画をお届けしております1回東京
の仕事が終わってちょっと日にちがあって帰ってきたんですけども数えて食べね今後は
静岡で東京にいることが多くなってくるんですよね挑戦がもう東京なんねえこんな
工藤ですねあの一番伝えなきゃいけないのかな
ちょっと考え伝えなきゃいけない人にまだ伝えてなくてですね
その方が
大家さんを家にまだ伝えてるんですよ
いや何かあのマーン末で伝えなきゃいけないんですけども別にこの静岡の家を引き払っ
ているわけでもないしずっと金続けてるんでなんかうまく言えなくてちょっとバタバタ
してて
ただ今後どうなるかわかんないんですちょっと東京に引っ越しましたということがの
話してないんでちょっと今から大家さんにそんな話をしてこようかなと思っております
大家さん
ほんと僕みたいなハチャメチャな妄想恩恵ですよ
そうおじさんねうるせーユーチューバーとがマジで迷惑だと思うんですよね絶対呉屋
さんとか済ませたくないと思うんですけど
そんな僕をですね心優しく何年間もこのうちに済ませていただいて本当に心から感謝し
ておりますし
僕あんまり人に心を開かないんですけどそんな僕がもう目
珍しいくらいで8日な年がある程度離れた方と親密な関係になれたなと思って
り素敵な方と巡り会えたっていうのもね静岡をてないってこういった要因の一つで
ございます
まぁ今日はそんな大谷さんとにちょっとこの引っ越しましたっていう話とか東洋の真珠
話とかそのことについてどう思うかとか
ひょっとしたらここを引き払って離れるかも
しれないなんて僕が東京行くことに対してどう思う方がちょっとね赤裸々に聞いてみ
たいと思います
まず大江さん love
[音楽]
おすすめします
を挿絵せませ突然フリーズで前と思います
[音楽]
これにって何ですかすべてのおもちゃえっ
尻尾は森田という可愛いかわいいでしょ
してい
[音楽]
アジアでございますお家さんお久しぶりを示す
ん
改めましてですねー
東京に
引っ越しましたおおあの時々見てました
ああありがとうございましたと言ってもですねまぁ多分未だ環境より
動画をよく取れるぞ東京では思ってなくてを介しているお部屋は残しつつ
公共で活動しよう
長井上性があると静岡に帰ってくるとかそれでまあ取得切ったわけではないんですけど
本当に何年間も餌には
をしたり乗ってたんでご挨拶有害いただきますこの動画を見て
5年ですかもう
5年だったんだ
動きる太ったな
1年に1キロ塔ですかもうさん的にはどう思われたんですか
まあ同然だろうなぁとでもご覧あった時言ってたじゃない
何東京を行くんでしょうと朝ですねあの時の社長の表現が
家に僕という70,000といいますが稲荷ないね
築地キツそうね
雰囲気はもう
そうな純そもそも大家さんと会う機会が入ったような気が歌しで支障が出るレベルに
なっ
1か月で10回を多くすると思っ
だけに30時間で夜寝るもんね
何して最近は頃なぁで車で行ってるんでしょ東京で運転でしょ
天罰してもらう溝さただもう乗っている時間がもったいない状態が1色2色
でまあいろいろ考えて結構焼却したんですけど
全国に拠点があるのはいいことだと思います選挙前全国全国
ね数字コロナで美貌とワーカーが増えん
ああ静岡にいるんだって言う
は悪いですけど日本たちになったスタートローが育ったのでほっとしたくん
もとなっていた
ひぁっああーっ30分毎で一度車ティ昔ほどその結果理系子がオスでも30手前て
やっぱり方々
40手前になると
これだけ動いとのに何も痩せないなぁ
たいした変わらないからねおかしいなぁもう10止めたろうかな
蛇買っちゃったヘリヘリコプター
どうでしたが僕が静岡の方針です見て
イェイドボーも何も光栄だと思いますね
最近は静かにありましてのもあるん
そのときっ
いっ
ファンの方とあっ来なくなりましたわけですよね
なんか積極的に怒ってると方ず入りましたにそれは良かっ
いやーやっぱ言わないとわかんないっすよ
ちゃんとどうもどうでした上去危なかっやっぱ今まったく見てがアホですか
逆に
初期の頃は警察の方とか相談させて頂いたりして
あの動画でここはね阿久津6セイフティ aba なった
席順会の開催場所ここで増えましたね
お家賃でもあげようかな
人が多いと思いすやっぱ九蔵ですね強いのか
それ
試してみる持って
まだわかんないね試しに行こうか
ぜひぜひ遊びに来てから是非それじゃよもうそれ11によっ
イオンですあ僕がよく行くのがその塔哉の塔かもしれないマジですか
ん
あれ名前打者でるんことが定宿になってるんだよあっそうなんですよねめっちゃ近いか
となるんじゃないこんなに感心ですね
なんだこれくしょ
へと言えません朝
いいえ
debian
はいねほんとに抑えが4沿い
ベンチプレスと思ってるブッダと通勤用のやつに戻ります
まず本当にも
ますから
水このてくれさあ立ったと思うんですけど
[音楽]
を持つに恒常化せていただいて時にはた人に誘っていただいたり車で奥誘拐をして
いただいたりご飯食べに行くと思っています
たりしていただき本当に
ありがとうございました構造計算上無理だと思いますなんか今のところ一体いつになり
そうですか
ん
さあ配列がちょっとまだ仕事の変動ではから泣き2を優しく東急行かれるって言うん
ですよ
ぜひぜひ次はん東京で飯食えます
5ありがとうございましたありがとうございます一区切りということで
[音楽]
と体実はしっかりしているそういうシャツ
パデッリ
あっちょ